Hi everyone, in your installing
software assignment, you were
asked to download Beekeeper
Studio. So I encourage you right
now to go ahead and launch
Beekeeper Studio, and it's going to
look something like this. But
what is Beekeeper Studio? It's a
fun name, but what is it? So it
is a free software application
that allows us to access our
databases and write SQL queries.
It is free, it works on
Windows, and it works
on Mac computers, so we
are thrilled about that.
We are going to be accessing our
databases that you are now familiar
with. Remember, databases are
comprised of tables that are
related to one another when we're
talking about relational databases.
Databases are homes for data,
so those tables include fields
and records of data that we can
store and maintain data quality.
but we are going to be writing
SQL queries and we need to be able
to access the data in our
databases and Beekeeper is going to
allow us to do that. So we are
going to access our databases that
are stored on AWS. You may have
heard of AWS. It's Amazon Web
Services. So it is a cloud platform
that has a variety of usages,
so many usages. We are going to
use it to store our databases. It
is an industry leader in cloud
architecture, IT infrastructure.
It is an industry leader. So it's
exciting that we are using AWS in
this class. But you're not going
to interact specifically with AWS.
You're going to be interacting with
Beekeeper. So I just want to set this
up. You're going to be writing
SQL queries in Beekeeper that is
going to be querying a database that
is held, it's stored on AWS. So it's
in the cloud if you want to think
of it that way. Okay, so it's in
the cloud. All right, but we need
to be able to have the credentials
to access our database via Beekeeper.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So make sure you've launched
Beekeeper. I have done this. I provided
the credentials by this above this
video so you can copy them that way
too. And we are going to select a
connection type initially. So we're
going to say SQL server is our
connection type. Now remember SQL
server is a relational database
management system. So the SQL server that
contains our databases is hosted
on AWS. All right. Now that won't
now that we have SQL Server,
here's our connection type.
The authentication method
is username and password.
The host is going to be really
important that we get this absolutely
correct. So this host is going to
be this AWS address right here. So
I'm going to copy this address and
I'm going to paste it into my host.
So make sure that you do that. Make
sure that it looks exactly like
mine does. you didn't accidentally
cut off the D in data or delete
M, anything like that. The port
is 1433. The username is data2100,
right? If we take back here,
yep, username is data2100. The
password is goaggies, capital G,
capital A, and exclamation point.
We are going to trust the
server certificate, it,
and we're not going to put in a default
database. We're going
to name this, though,
Data 2100 SQL Server.
So I'm going to come down
here and say Data 2100 SQL
Server, and we are going to
have this connection be the
color blue. We're going to
go ahead and press Test,
and the connection looks
good. Perfect. So I'm going
to say Save. Alright, awesome.
So now my connection is
saved. So let's come over
here and double click on Data
2100 SQL Server. So double
click on this connection.
And what it's going to do is it's going
to open up basically the selection
of databases that are available
to me. And I have Overland, right?
And I also, which we are familiar
with, we introduced that. I also
have databases like dbvac, dbvac-hr.
We will use those for other things.
But for now, we're going to
be in my Overland database.
We looked at our Overland ERD and
Data Dictionary, and we saw that there
were these different tables in
Overland. So we can see that our tables
exist over here. So I can take a
look at those. And then right here
on query number one, this will
automatically pop up a query sheet. and
this query sheet we can write so we
can write comments with two dashes
okay and then we can write a query
which we will start which we will
start doing here within my query sheet
so I just wanted to orient you to
beekeeper this connection will save
so don't worry about that but if
something does go awry, you can watch
this video again and see that. The
other thing that I wanted to make
note is we will be saving our queries
in Word documents to turn in. So
if you ever want to save queries, I
just recommend copying them all and
pasting them into some other file.
I don't save query sheets here, so
I would just exit out of this and
delete that query sheet. So I could
create another query sheet here, but
I don't save anything here within
Beekeeper. So just keep that in mind.
All right, thanks everybody for
all of your hard work in this
class. Go ahead and let's introduce
you to writing SQL queries.